hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm
checking out the call of duty black ops
3 e3 2015 multiplayer reveal trailer
this was sent to me by a few people this
specific video I'm having unfortunate
luck where there's a few game videos
that have been sent to me but apparently
they're not the complete one but this is
the one Noah sent to me by sub so I'm
going with this one
so duffle bag Tony Kubik a heavy dog
he's been a piece
ah
Oh
so Jules
watching that brother
a little more violent
ah
great
got it sweet [ __ ] sweet man
that was really cool oh man that was
really [ __ ] cool I can't wait to buy
this game ah you know like I know a lot
of people have actually been complaining
about the fact that their futuristic
these days the Call of Duty games but I
kind of like that I I personally like
the change-up that they're doing making
it more futuristic you get to do more
[ __ ] cuz like I feel like having a
futuristic adds two more types of guns
different kinds of killstreaks like more
Maps if they just released like a world
war 2 game again it just would have been
a little repetitive I mean I know that
you Call of Duty had more of a realism
before but yeah it's a [ __ ] video
game and I like the fact that they're
going all out with the futuristic stuff
man it looks cool and just as a trend
alone that song [ __ ] rocked that was
really cool I love the way it played
over that and I'm getting a PlayStation
4 finally in just a couple days actually
and I think Call of Duty is now a
PlayStation exclusive which kind of
sucks but sorry for all you guys who
don't have a PlayStation 4 but I do now
so haha but you not [ __ ] you that's me
come on Xbox one - yeah I'm excited for
the futuristic game point mainly because
of the new kind of weapons the weapons
look [ __ ] sweet I'm so buying this I
think I ready have it pre-order on
Amazon actually but yeah I'm gonna be
getting it anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you're new you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
boss on Facebook Instagram Twitter and
vine because if we get more followers we
can get even more product placement more
money
Kevin Claire hey the real rejects thank
you for enlightening my day and always
making me smile you can turn every
sentence into a joke haha not that one
not to mention that I'm glad you're
starting to do gaming videos on your
channel by the way I love gaming keep up
the good work and I can't wait to see
more from you guys you're awesome
Kevin Claire if you love gaming you and
I could be friends I am pretty behind on
game
so that's why I'm gonna start buying
systems now because I got to get
up-to-date Kevin um you look like young
Conan O'Brien you might be so young that
you don't even know who Conan O'Brien is
what Conan O'Brien in case anyone asks
to you Conan is a sexy freckled redhead
dude probably freckly down they're not
saying you are too young to imply that
but what are the odds you know